[Music]
somehow this concept of connectivity is
intimately linked to the concept of
complexity and so really what I'm saying
is that the universe is getting its act
together it's connecting the dots it's
bringing everything into co-relationship
with everything else and somehow it does
this through the production of
consciousness consciousness is this
integrate a function in biology which
takes data which may appear profoundly
unrelated and in fact brings it into
some kind of a congruent relationship we
say an organism coordinates a point of
view well in a way what's happening over
time is that the universe is
coordinating a point of view and as it
does this it becomes somehow more aware
more self-conscious more being like and
less thing like you could almost say
that nature abhors habit and so it seeks
the novel by producing various kinds of
phenomena at every level in biology
chemistry and Society and so there
really is a purpose to the universe its
purpose is this state of hyper
complexification in which all of its
points become related to each other
become what mathematicians call
cotangent and it gives the universe the
feeling of being imbued with a caring
presence well the great watershed
difference between the archaic
understanding and what is called
scientific materialism is the archaic
mind understood in fact perceived that
nature is conscious nature is alive
nature is an organism full of intent
the goal of the archaic mind is to
connect with communicate with and align
itself to this greater gyein holism
which is sometimes called nature the
Great Spirit the realm of the ancestors
but this is what the archaic mind
understood and was comfortable with and
in fact it is true our own decision to
view the universe as dead as inanimate
as unintelligent allowed us permitted us
to dissect it use it and and deny its
validity outside of human purpose now
the consequences of living like that is
coming back to haunt us you know we have
almost destroyed our home we have almost
cut the earth from beneath our own feet
so this impulse toward the dynamic and
the and the archaic is a survival
instinct at this point we must give
reverence and credence to nature and
nature's methods because no other
methods will allow us to work our way
out of the present mess we're in
high-temperature high energy resource
extraction commodification mega
agriculture we're at the end of the rope
for these things so the archaic holds
answers but it only holds answers if we
are willing to think of the universe as
a living intelligent entity in with
which we are in partnership not set
against but that in fact we are a part
of a Morpho genetic intent
and an unfolding reality that is larger
than human understanding
imagine larger than human understanding
[Laughter]
[Music]
somebody told me a wonderful story which
you should know because you might you
know draw a comfort from it sky was very
pretty experienced he'd taken fairly
high doses of mushrooms before and he
took a six gram dose on a Saturday
evening in his apartment in LA and this
heart thing began to develop that he
identified as a fibrillation or
something so he tried to cold it back
and keep not know this and not it kept
getting stronger and strong it never
lets you do that by the way the not
noticing it's a paradox you didn't take
this to not notice so eventually he
becomes thoroughly alarmed and he tries
to call a couple of his friends well
it's Saturday night nobody's home so
then just this tremendous sense of
abandonment settles over this guy his
friends aren't there when he needs him
he's going to die here in his apartment
and be found days later so forth and so
on and he gets this ball rolling see so
finally he despairs he's a
psychotherapist and MD blah blah
everything he despairs he calls 900
so they come they get him they rush him
to the hospital they put him in a ward
they any by the time all this has
happened and he's gotten all this
attention and probably a little second
all he's feeling pretty good about it
all so then he says to the guy on duty
he says I I feel like I have to tell you
I took psilocybin mushrooms do you think
that that brought this on and the guy
said no you had an anxiety attack we get
people with this all the time we don't
know anything about psychedelic drugs so
you know it isn't the drug you have to
worry about it's yourself you have to
discipline your hindbrain
you have to be able to say listen shut
up we're gonna come through this just
shut up about it because it's saying but
don't you think we should call somebody
we shouldn't treat it with such levity
because it is a serious issue I mean
I've been in many circumstances where
vital signs seem to have fallen so low
in my own perception that I just was
saying to myself keep breathing keep
looking keep breathing keep looking and
I felt you know that we I was in a
submarine five and a half miles down
easy does it through here breaths
attention breath attention because you
have the feeling that if you don't keep
your attention on your breath you will
simply stop breathing
well now it's interesting people who
don't worry much about psychedelics you
tell them a story like that and they say
well isn't that the bit that you take
these drugs and you think you're dying
and then you get straight and then you
don't die and then you're really happy
isn't that what it's supposed to do I
thought that was what it was about well
in fact if you go back into the
literature in the 1960s the Tibetan Book
of the Dead crowd was saying you will be
flung from hell to paradise and back
again on about a 40-minute schedule for
several hours and they prepared
themselves for these bad trip situations
by anticipating it and I I don't release
think there's that much to it I think
your mind is very fragile in that state
and you know a bad thought quickly
becomes a cascade and you have to know
how to
this how to stock these cascades very
practical technique that I use is I take
a hit of cannabis thinking you're going
to die at least for me is not all that
rare I mean if somebody invites me to go
sailing with them on the bay on a Sunday
afternoon at least twice in the
afternoon I will sign off completely and
just assume that's it you know maybe I'm
a little paranoid you know or maybe I
have crazy friends
[Music]
mushrooms are my thing I mean that they
enlightened me they straightened me out
they love me but a little bit the way to
do mushrooms is the very first move if
you're interested in mushrooms is for
god sake buy a scale buy a scale I mean
you wouldn't think that this would be
considered such an exotic suggestion to
people who are going to put their bodies
and minds on the line because people
don't take enough people do not take
enough mushrooms they take pissant
amounts and then they claim that their
initiates you must take a measured five
dried grams on an empty stomach
measured and when you see what that is
you'll realize that you know you weren't
even camped in the atrium you were
camped in the driveway and mushrooms to
my in some ways
I mean DMT is the most terrifying an
astonishing thing in the universe but
it's very hard to know what to do with
it
psilocybin is your friend it wants to
teach it will take you by the hand and
forgive you and lead you and be with you
and it's speed this is the amazing thing
and you're hearing this from you know
somebody who graduated from Heidegger
and FH Bradley it speaks no other
psychedelic does that in my experience
occasionally a phrase will pop into your
head on another substance that is like a
gift to mass tourism but I mean
psilocybin raves it raves and it has
positions I mean you may not like
psilocybin as a person because it is not
it the astonishing thing about the
psilocybin entity it to my mind and I
get through it confirmation of this is
it is not very earthly
I mean it wants to show you machines the
size of Manhattan in orbit around alien
stars it wants to talk about the sweep
through of the little hood uh which
happened before the earth cooled and it
you know has seen the empires of the
roll out at the rim and all the rest of
it and it's very puzzling this cosmic
Galactic Aryan tome because then you
switch over to ayahuasca
which is literally just a twist of the
molecule just tiniest tweaking of the
molecule and suddenly it's about
childbirth rivers the land the feminine
looking inside your body curing disease
feeling telepathy communication it could
hardly be more different and yet
chemically these things are like to two
sides of the same coin
yes first come the dancing my the little
candies the colored grids and so forth
and so on but what eventually happens
quickly like ten minutes later
is there is an entity in the trance in
the vision there is a mine there waiting
that speaks good English and invites you
up into its room what it is is it's a
voice in the head
that people strove to attain for a
thousand years this was the scene a
quinone of intellectual accomplishment
in the greco-roman world and the logos
told you the right way to live and this
is sort of what you get with psilocybin
you get a voice that can confound you
with the depth and brilliance of the
dancers this is what you want and I've
had over and over the experience of
showing somebody what five grams is and
they're appalled they think like God you
can't be serious I mean I would I take a
bit
much afford that much yeah well that's
the problem that's why you Neville's in
the attic and bats in the belfry like
I'm do a lot of people have said you're
a hallucination not you're obsessed with
hallucination I freely admit it
but I will defend my obsession with
vision I think the world wants to be
seen I think Blake was right that the
divine imagination is something beheld
and for me the visions are the proof
that this is not my mind and the visions
are the proof that this is not simply
chemical chaos in the nervous system and
when we communicate with each other and
understand each other we instinctively
reach for visual metaphors I see what
you mean
look here Noah she painted a picture his
words were so beautiful it means that we
really associate meaning with seeing
something there is something about us
that causes us to a dict to everything
we addicted territory and then we'll
kill to defend it we a dick to each
other if any of you have ever been
unexpectedly left by a sexual partner
the symptoms of that are exactly like
the symptoms of withdrawal from heroin
you burst into tears unexpectedly you
vomit every few hours you hide in
darkened rooms you can't face people you
don't want to go anywhere you you are
withdrawing and it's exactly the same
thing we add it to each other then we a
dick - all forms of behavior - routine
you know ludwig von bertalanffy the
founder of general Systems Theory said
human beings are not machines but in
every case where they are given the
opportunity to behave like machines they
will choose to do so
so did this and this is why we need an
external input to dissolve our
programming we apparently evolved with
this need and in societies where
psychedelics are not available poor
substitutes have have been put in place
starvation flagellation a sonic driving
oh I don't know of complicated
visualizations and so forth
these are stopgap measures to try to ass
wage and direct this this virulent need
of ours to a dick to something well when
you take the tendency to a dick to
behaviors and cultural modes and so
forth and weld it to the demonic
capacity of modern technology to produce
more powerful drugs than have ever been
known before and in greater amounts so
that laboratories can produce literally
tens of millions of doses of cocaine or
heroin can could be produced in rural
laboratories in Burma or Colombia and
then you have a global transportation
and delivery system that within 24 hours
can have this stuff on the street in
Frankfurt Bangkok Tokyo it means that we
have to take hold of ourselves
and realize what is going on the dark
side of ourselves married to technology
can just carry us to hell in a
handbasket without any difficulty at all
if we don't quickly and radically
revised our relationship to
things so the issue
strangely enough which lies directly
ahead of us on the historical continuum
is in fact the issue of drugs and more
broadly the issue of addiction what we
are doing to ourselves unexamined
habitual behavior patterns and after all
isn't that what we object to about hard
drugs isn't that what is so offensive
about the anything addict the heroin
addict the television addict the thing
addict is that when it comes time for
their fix
whether it be st. elsewhere or whatever
do not stand in these people's way you
know they are going for the button they
are going for the syringe whatever it is
[Music]
imagine for a moment that anything was
possible imagine for example that the
laws of physics were suddenly replaced
with the laws of the imagination well
that's a very interesting meditation
because it starts out at least for me I
think well if I could have anything what
would I have or what would I like to
have if I could have anything so it
begins modestly I would somehow transfer
to the Vatican Library to Versailles and
I would live at her side and have access
to the Vatican Library and all other
books and works of art that have ever
existed and I would walk in a garden but
then I start thinking like this and I
say no but the question was what would
it be like if that could be anything why
would you want a fair sign why would you
want the Vatican
very you if you could have anything and
you realize our imagination is
completely constrained by the laws of
physics
what would we become if we could become
anything I mean if I could snap my
fingers and you were omnipotent what
would you do the first thing I would do
is I would fly I would just leave about
three hundred thousand feet in the air
and gives the cowboy a yell
but them you that realize you know the
entire universe is now your model yet
them across the galaxy in the wink of an
eye you can journey back to the Big Bang
in the time it takes to think about it
there is no civilization in the history
of the cosmos no work of art no ecstasy
no experience that is behind you and I
maintain that we would become within
minutes of this transformation
unrecognizable to ourselves because we
are completely defined by our
limitations and and so that's what I
imagine death is it's the discovery that
you can be do see think and feel
anything when was the last time that you
were actually sick with amazement but
when was the last time you were actually
white with sheer terror probably unless
you've been caught him out of multi all
accidents er landslides it was a
psychedelics
because these things deliver
authentic emotion authentic data and the
the bottom bit of history is that it
deep attentions human dividuals just in
order to live inside the historical
society you have to stop yourself down
and down and down you mustn't be in
other people's face you mustn't trust
your ethnicity or your gender your
tattoo or whatever it is - you mustn't
flaunt everything is confined this is
the attitude of history it's what's
called being part of the public it's
something necessary for democracies to
do business there has to be a public but
when we identified with the public and
we essentially become creatures of the
curly and there is no peace until the
there is no leather and pressure until
the end as we approach the
transcendental option at the end of time
history moves faster and faster
we have been approaching this
transcendental object since before there
was a way to speak of in human terms in
other words this is the same attractor
that holds life out of the oceans cause
primates to stand on their hind legs and
so forth and so on but obviously pick a
number about 20,000 years ago ten
thousand years ago the process quickened
we turned the corner everything began to
move faster and again at the fall of
Rome faster faster and again in the 20th
century faster faster faster
well nobody has drawn the obvious
conclusion from this if we're going
faster and faster faster and faster then
hell we're gonna get somewhere pretty
soon
and and that's where I think we are we
can hardly go any faster without the
speed of our acceleration passing into
the domains of humanly colonize about
time in other words the reason things
are getting weirder and weirder is
because the space-time continuum itself
is accelerating it's entirely possible
that the last half of the life of the
universe will happen in about 3% of the
total life of the universe nobody said
that it has to take this long going down
as it took to come up it may be that the
coming up took a long long time and the
going down can be catastrophic sudden
unexpected dynamic we say and that's why
I take and I return to this thing
because as I return to all things that
history is an anticipation
history is the last call that the train
is leaving the station
you know the colleg goes back to chuck
tall Julia and slightly beyond but in
our own lifetime it's now palpable you
know all you have to do is close your
eyes in a quiet place twist up a bomber
please and you will behold the
transcendental object at the end of time
you can feel it in form in your own life
I mean you spend a good deal of time
denying it because rationalist tell you
you're either losing your mind or it's
impossible and it can't be happening
but this sense of plotted nosaka nected
Nastase sense that we are all in a
universal drama playing to a close this
sense that we are larger than ourselves
that we are somehow characters on a
stage this is a phenomenon of the light
at Eventide this is a phenomenon of the
final
of the cosmic drama and I think it's
tremendously exciting I think this is
what nature said about 700 million years
ago on this planet that it's not about
chipmunk after two months after chipmunk
for Yonder he'll I mean a little of that
goes a long ways I'm sure you'll agree
with me that's all very fine but the way
nature works is she builds upon her
complexity we can feel that we're more
than animals we have this dimension
which we call spiritual which and some
of us buy it which is some off-the-shelf
explanation Catholicism or - Janus of
something like that others of us wrestle
with it or we smart this board it and -
you know a little table a little dowel
is
little Tantra hafsat isms doesn't matter
you know do that but whatever it is we
wrestle with this part of ourselves
which cannot be simply dismissed
there is monkey meat and I think that it
is
the soul that the soul is actually an
entity in history seeking to be born and
that the enterprise of history is the
creation of the collectivity as an
eternal indestructible transdimensional
object of some sort the tool at the end
of time
[Music]
I've told the story about how Indy
Amazon when all this stuff was breaking
loose I went through this period where
very calmly and deeply and without
having any need to tell anyone I thought
I came to the opinion that I was like
enlightened and it was this very low-key
thing it was all about appropriate
behavior
this was the cognitive hallucination
that I was having it was about
appropriate behavior and I had this idea
there's an appropriate way to do
everything and if you do it the
appropriate way no energy will be lost
and so you become like superconducting
you become like some kind of super Tai
Chi character where you just do things
Sonne Italy that there's no problem
whether it's plucking a flower or moving
a boulder and I was told when you think
sit on the ground this was there were
all these teachings and they were very
simple they were things like sit on the
ground stupid and you know use your
fingers that was a big teaching use your
fingers so one of the things I was into
was how you wash the pot we had one pot
it was this little enamel pot and we
would bake it over a fire and we baked
beans and we baked rice and all these
terrible things that would get skull on
the bottom and so it was a big deal
about drawing lots for who washed the
pot well I discovered in my enlightened
state that we had been doing it all
wrong
and that if you would go down to the
water with the pot and and take sand and
Pat it very very lightly in the bottom
and then say please but then all you had
to do was pour water into the pot and
swish it around and empty it like that
and then when you looked in it would be
like Drano you know it would just be
blinding white and I did this several
times and I thought how appropriate a
miracle this is this is a real miracle I
mean this is just simple stuff it's
totally errant now it's absolutely galas
it's completely you know on and off so
then I had a critic in our crowd and so
I thought that I would enlighten the
critic by a wordless demonstration of my
obvious command of the howling Dow so I
invited the critic to accompany me to
the river and and I said and now notice
that I pick up the pan I pass it into
the bottom
I'm not agitating it I look into the sky
and I say please
and then I put water in it and I swish
it around Wow said is something supposed
to happen and I look and the cruddud
here and then this person says you know
I pity and I would pity you more but you
alarm
[Laughter]
[Music]
it is upon us every Messiah every
religious ontology every manager of
every booth that this exhibit is
reflecting a distorted scintilla of the
spiritual reality of the transcendental
object at the end of time every one of
us is a particular eyes and distorted
image of this transcendental object into
which we are being dissolved into which
global culture is dissolved so
[Music]
well so but so we can cut into this
cycle at any point we can become aware
of it we can become part of it we can
deny it there is no loss in the circuit
there is no blame becoming them when
psychedelic means is it means claiming
this dimension as your own you know
Plato said time is the moving image of
eternity that moving image of eternity
can be beheld in the silent darkness of
the mind on five grams of psilocybin and
if you if you think the universe is
Monday if you think there are no more
frontiers to cross no more adventures to
be had I'm telling you you can turn your
living room into the bridge of
Magellan's on a long Saturday evening
with 5 grams of psilocybin and silent
darkness we are living in the most
empowering age in human history because
all of the energy of the ancestors not
only the human ancestors but our animal
our primate ancestors all that energy
porous entity is focused into this
moment we are the transition generation
we have one who is in matter and one
foot in hyperspace and we can redeem
the trust of thousands of years all of
the horror of history can be redeemed if
we don't drop the ball every patrol
every instance of racial sexual or
minority persecution can be redeemed if
we do the human adventure meaning and we
giveth meaning by discovering the
totality within ourselves
and then amplifying it for each other
and this dissolves boundaries empowers
the weak enlightens the straw and brings
hope to all and it can only be done if
we accept the gifts which make sure has
offered us thank you very very much
the last thought I want to leave you
with which is a sort of coincidentally a
positive thought because it will bum
some and exalt others is the one thing
that I've learned from psychedelics that
seems secure over all the decades and
the you know embracing one idea one in D
ology after another the one thing that
seems secure is a truth that is hard to
hear in the context of a dominator
culture with the obsession with the
material world and and that truth is
that nothing lasts nothing lasts you
know your enemies will fade your friends
will fade your fortune your poverty your
disappointments your dreams everything
is in the process of changing into
something else so your agony is about to
be ass waged on the other hand your
happiness is about to be destroyed so
the the obligation that comes out of
this realization is an obligation to the
in the immediate moment to this thing
that I've been calling the felt moment
of immediate experience it isn't who you
were or what you were or who you will be
or what you will be it's the felt moment
of immediate experience and this has
been robbed from us by media and by our
tendency to
denigrate ourselves to see the world in
terms of the great ones not here whoever
they are Aristotle
Madonna Jesus whatever your particular
band is the overcoming of neuroses of
unhappiness of toxic lifestyles is the
felt presence of immediate experience in
the body in the moment and you know
psychedelics sexuality gastronomy sport
dance these are the things which put you
in the felt presence of the moment and
that's really all you ever possess your
memories are eroding away the futures
you anticipate will mostly not come to
pass and the real richness is in the
moment and it's not necessarily some
kind of be here now feel-good thing
because it doesn't always feel good but
it always me
it is a domain of feeling its primary
language is not primary ideology is not
primary the propagation of future and
past vectors is not primary what's
primary is the felt presence of
experience and that is the source of
love and that is the source of community
if so if someone had never taken
psychedelics and had no interest in it
and had come here because they thought
this was the triggering group I think
they would be truly alarmed and
disturbed by what they hear because we
appear to be mad people because we
appear to be fully engaged with an
unseen invisible world we're calling it
the cause of history the purpose for the
future and the basis for everything
going on between us but nobody said life
was simple because every single person
who does this is seeing things no human
eye has ever fallen upon and it is a
realm of ideas and we do each bring back
different souvenirs from that place we
are all equally qualified we don't know
who will spot the whale but everyone
should have their eye peeled because
that's what we're doing we're searching
for an encounter with Leviathan nature
is God that was the informing vision of
Moby Dick and it's a good one to carry
as a metaphor into this
to the psychedelic experience there
again was a perfect example of the male
ego unable to release into the matrix of
nature until it literally dragged them
into the depths through the building of
community through the music and the
dissolution of boundaries through the
use of these psychedelics the Shaymin
are showing how you create an archaic
style culture after 5,000 years of human
history because we can't abandon
technology we have six billion people on
this planet but the Shamer and the rave
culture are showing us how we can take
what was best in the society of 25,000
years ago and bring it into the center
of our lives and live it again
and create a community of caring
intelligent people who've got their
heart connected to their head and their
heart connected to their feet so that
through dance feeling philosophy
sexuality art we manifest the creativity
that is going to be necessary for us to
save ourselves this is the key you see
if the expansion of consciousness does
not play a major role in the human
future what kind of future is it going
to be
my goals are very modest I'm very
pleased that it chose to confide so
concrete an idea in me but if it had
never chosen to do that I still would
die a happy man with the unspeakable
experiences of beauty that it has shared
with me because my psychedelic trips
these days are not about the time life
the time wave is pretty much a done a
done deal
so I think it's like everything else in
life intent is everything and
impeccability means in that domain do
not seek to use do not seek to use it's
a religious mystery and that doesn't
mean it's an unsolved problem it means a
mystery and life is only worth living as
long as the mysteries continue to inform
transform and inspire us and the last
thing I want to say and then I'll leave
you is the truth can take care of itself
you don't have to approach the truth
with eyes lower than gaze averted on
bended knee that's how you approach
[ __ ]
but the truth is so powerful that you
can kick the tires turn over the engine
check the odometer and nobody is
offended truth is real
it can stand the test and that's why you
know I went all over the world looking
at various spiritual traditions I don't
feel it's putting them down to say that
they were ineffective because they were
all great aspirations but the only real
open doorway that I ever found were the
planes this works you know in other
spiritual disciplines everybody wants to
go faster they want the Roshi to give
them further empowerment they want
further information postures secret
teachings so forth and so on once you
reach the psychedelic experience the
accelerator is far less interesting than
the location of the brakes that's what
we're looking for we're not trying to
push we all know how to push this so
fast we can't stand it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we need a feeling of unity feeling is
primary
[Music]
so it doesn't come out an intellectual
excerpt Asian it comes out of a personal
act of courage made by the individual an
act of courage which involves surrender
surrender is the opposite side of the
coin of ego the central issue of our
times is our inability to surrender to
what we know is right we have the
ability to feed the hungry we have the
ability to educate our children to clean
up our environment to eliminate sexism
to eliminate racism the question is can
we change our minds fast enough not can
we change our minds but can be changed
them fast enough
a return to archaism with the lessons
learned in history that's where we were
happy the fall was a fall into a veil of
Tears into a world of limitation and
pain and suffering and infectious
disease and so forth and so on
it's a prodigal journey into a lower
dimension that can now be ended by a
collective cultural decision to commit
to this taoist shamanistic feminized
cybernetic caring aware
present kind of being I mean it's
nothing more than what each of us is in
our very best moments but we have to
extend those very best moments to fill
whole lifetimes
[Music]
that's interesting
the age thing that's great
oh man makini it must be approaching
2012 now
[Music]
you
[Music]